Well, I appreciate you being here, uh,
before we get into all of your stories and you've got quite a bit here on the
list, will you please plug, promote everything you want? Sure, sure.
I'm all over the road this year. Uh,
hit me on Mark Norman comedy.com. Instagram Twitter.
A podcast is called Tuesdays with stories with Joe list.
He's a cute kid and we had him here on that great episode
and uh, yeah. Yeah. Check me out. Come see me live. Uh, before I kill myself,
please say you can say you saw me win.
Save me before I go full gay. Come on in people.
Sorry about the sunglasses. Um, culturally appropriating, uh, a jazz musician.
There we go. There you go. Ah, the lights.
Going hard and the pain, huh? I like her. All right. Hey. Hey. Hey,
you got a tenant and you just said that he doesn't watch porn.
You seem a little pent up. I never watched porn. Wow.
And I haven't watched porn in men,
but I do it every day and it's gotta be black. Yeah.
But I don't know. How do you, how do you do it? You, what do you imagination?
Like eighth grade style? Uh, I I'm older. I just, I don't know. Yeah.
I don't think back to, I don't even turn off,
back off in black and white anymore. Really? I swear to God.
I'm just like, dude, get the out. You're sitting. You're weird.
I bet. That's brilliant. I met him. He's better than yeah.
Uh, alpha. He wins. He wins. Yeah.
We're in New York and it feels more like, Oh,
that was a clever take on that joke. And it was,
it feels more already a little bit like a little more intellectually, like,
like David tells, I mentioned he looks like a hobo. Right.
But he's just brilliant guy. You know.
He's alive. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you always have somebody like that in the building that makes you check that
checks the, all the levels? Yes. It's like,
even if he's not personally doing it, it's just him being there.
There's a ceiling as to what's going on.
Yeah. But then you go to the comedy store, I'm in the main room green room.
And you're like, look, all these sexy dudes, you know, like Brennan shoves,
a chiseled fat. Like he's got the slick hair,
the cool shoes got a chain on. I'm like,
I would never even think to put on a chain.
The white part of bacon. Yeah. It's called the white part of bacon. Still good.
But boy, little thick and not good.
Yeah. He's a thick crust. And he's got the cheese in there too. You know,
you stretch it and it pulls.
But I was like, dang. I was.
Jesus. I know. I know. But he's like seven foot one.
He's got a huge piece of bad. It's crazy. One leg dude is.
It's a penis with a kneel.
Wow. He's got a bendy Dick. He's got ligaments.
Oh dude. Yeah. He can stand on his deck. Yeah.
It's pretty crazy. It's a kickstand, a Dick Stan. Uh, all, all the Europe ones,
you know, getting loose in Amsterdam, we got loose. We, you know,
just did the canals and get, uh, got a bunch of weed drug guy. Nah,
not a weed guy. I can't do it. I'm too up. That weed brings out all the demons.
It doesn't suppress them like alcohol what'd you mean like booze and uppers?
Yeah. Yeah. You don't seem like a lost, you have your darkness.
It's from your childhood. I think. So you had a weird childhood. How so? Well,
let's see. My dad got a wild hair up his and bought a mansion,
dilapidated mansion in a poor black neighborhood. So first of all,
the house was. We barely had running water. It was, you know,
we'd have family meetings like, all right, go at school. Don't here.
We need the water. And then my dad started running out of money.
So he made the back half a bed and breakfast, like old style.
But so my mom's whipping up pancakes at 8:00 AM and I'm like, can I get one?
She's like blow big Dick, eat a bowl of Cheerios. Gunt. And so I was like,
all right, sorry. Jesus. And so,
you know there's so my parents were workaholics. They're checked out. You know,
they, they, they were nice people, but they're just like, Hey,
we gave birth to you. You figure it out. Yeah. Go watch TV.
There's no attention. Yes. Dr. Drew,
I just common baby boy said give him attention.
So what Dr. Doosan. So he said you're uh, cause I was like, my mom didn't react.
Like I have girlfriends. I'll introduce her to my mom. They're like, whew.
That was tough. I felt like I was bombing in there. I'm like welcome to my life.
You. Jesus Christ. I'm 20 years of that growing up and uh,
last from straight. Like asked me a question. Just ask me a random question.
Um, my mom, um, a random question. Um, where are you from?
What time is it? Where are we going to get at? It's just like, Oh. Sorry. Yeah.
And it's, she's not mean, she's just like, she's just got her checked out.
She just like thinking about, I gotta pay the bill, I got to water the plants,
you know? And you're like, you have brothers and sisters, older brother.
And he's a genius. He's like this, you know, math and computer wizard.
And our neighborhood was so dangerous that he just head into a computer,
like as a kid. And he just became like DAS and.
You make friends in the neighborhood with the black. Yeah. Yeah.
But then you got into fights and there was a lot of racial tension.
It was the nineties and bikes were stolen and we got robbed all the time.
We had this crazy alarm going off because our house was so big and you would
just,
I'd be like an eight year old kid and you'd just hear like glass breaking and
then.
Woo. I'm just like, ah.
I'm in my room. Like hugging up Teddy, you know,
hoping I don't get raped by Leroy. And uh, you know, you go downstairs and Hey,
the TV is gone today. You know? And that was, that was a Tuesday.
And we got robbed all the time. My dad he's got like, he's like, N-word rich.
You know where he's like, Oh, we're going to buy a Lexus, but it's Alexis,
you know? So the Lexus would get stolen and he's like, all right, he'll,
he'll give me like cab money to go to school and. And uh,
and that was just how it was. I remember I told the store on Rogan,
but I got my bike stolen. Just, just street Tufts, you know,
they would rub their front tire on your back tire. And that meant like a, your.
And they would just take your bike.
Forever. I didn't get a good night's sleep, but that did end up working.
Oh really? It worked for both of them. It didn't.
Work for me. I tried these dehydration pills, like to dry you out.
That didn't work. And then my dad,
eventually we got so fed up because he was annoyed with the bedwetting.
He's like, you got to grow up, be a loser. So he said no more liquids after six.
So I'm sitting there eating Doritos at six Oh eight going like, you know,
I look like a, like a Somali pirate. I'm so thirsty. I'm like,
it's like Waterworld. I got to pee in a jar and filter it. You know,
I'm so thirsty. And I'm, you know, my brother's gov judge guzzling,
a Kool-Aid and and Pepsi. And I'm like.
He's not having that problem at all. It was brutal.
Oh man, that was a dry County. And so you would,
would you not go to sleep overs because of it?
I would go cause I wanted to hang and I wanted to, you know,
be a part of society. I'd want to be like a weirdo, like disabled guy.
Like I can't go, I have a problem. So I would just stay up all night.
And it was like, I was like in a Holocaust death camp, I was like, all right,
I'll sleep in shifts. You know,
split for like 10 minutes here and I'll wake up and I saw everything.
I would just walk around my friend's houses at like two in the morning.
They're they're snoozing and I'd go through the mom's panties and you know,
watch some TV and check the fridge.
I was like a weird night owl Nightcrawler guy at like nine, you know,
checking out porn, you know,
I'm going in and out of the house playing with a cat,
whatever I had to do jerk off on a friend's face. Anything just kill the time.
Did you guys jerk off together? You and your buds? No, never. Oh,
that was a big one and none of the w okay, so let's talk about that too,
because was it a circle jerk thing or what was it.
Were like, nah.
You take a corner, I'll take a corner. We got the porn in the middle and uh,
yeah, it was like a bonding experience.
I did make my friend taste it once and he never talked to me again.
[Inaudible].
Like, I dare you to taste. He's like, I'm not tasting. I was like a double dog.
And he was like, Hey Jay, you know, it was a great moment.
I mean, we're still cool. He's he's dead.
Now. He was a gay porn star.
When I was growing up, they had a thing for gyp. And for a while,
girls would put a LSD in their vagina.
Home.
A Dick trip. Your Dick will go in and get all burning, man. That was the thing.
Yeah. Whoa.
The girl was tripping. Then you get in there and get some of the trip.
Is this real?
I don't mind a trip, but I don't want to through my Dick hole.
That's that's a weird spot.
That's a way. That's a wow. That's a wild entrance. That's a front. So positive.
Holy hell. Uh, Nick. Nick's a creeper. Well,
he's a premature baby dude making up for lost time.
You came out good.
That's what I'm saying, man.
Why a lot of these guys go on 36 and Nick got out early, bro.
Oh yeah. I was like a seasick really? Oh yeah.
I came out through the roof. Oh, wow. I guess maybe.
The mood rooms or something.
That I didn't come up through the door.
I could see you being like, I don't know. You know,
is this the best thoroughfare? Right. See what else?
And you've all touched your mom's badge. I haven't touched, well,
maybe you've touched my mom's. She's a big, but uh,
I haven't touched my mom's vagina, which feels pretty good. Oh yeah.
Oh that I guess I could see that there is always a weird element.
I think sometimes when I look at my mom and she, and I both know it.
I did. Yeah. Yeah.
You ruined her Libya for awhile and they say it goes back.
Yeah, I hear it's never exactly the same, but that's my buddy said that, Oh.
Well maybe had a big kid or something. Yeah. He said though,
because we've all banged some milks and it didn't feel that different.
Yeah. I don't have any feelings in my penis.
At all. I don't feel well. Come on.
I don't think so. I mean, it all, so many of the nerves were in my brain,
so it's like, if I think hard enough, I can feel something,
but otherwise it's kind of like, uh, wait, are you serious? Yeah. I'm just not,
I mean, yeah. Like not very sensitive downtown.
I think so. I don't know. You're not just all over really. Oh,
I put it in. I'm done. Oh yeah. I mean, and don't worry.
I got the brain stuff too. I'm going and I hate myself. I'm tiny.
I'm gay all this, but I don't have the, uh, the band back together.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. My like a, like a girl at seeing the notebook.
It's just weeping. It's bad.
Bro. The first time I ever had sex, I remember getting right up.
Like literally my penis was right outside of this girl's um,
vagina. And it just like sneezed, you know?
Just like, like it was so nervous or something. Yeah.
So it hit the out. So it, it, it pressure washed. Oh definitely.
And it was like a, it was almost like, he was like, Oh,
I'm too sick to handle this, this vomited outside of this girl's entryway,
you know, puked at the table. He didn't even get to the buffet. Oh,
I didn't hear. Oh.
Man. You golden corralled. And.
We were so ready. Everybody was so ready. So then at 10,
like I was so ready bro. And that was crazy. Cause I had to like, Oh, hold on.
I don't want to just do this. I don't want to make up this long.
Right. Um, all right, please, please tear. I,
I do want to talk to you about dating though.
So please all these problems going on the bed wedding, the, this, the, that,
what age do you start getting into girls and actually dating.
And how old are you when you lose your virginity?
I was such a mess like anxiety wise insecurity wise that I couldn't
pick up a lady.
I had to be boozing and she had to be booze and I w I had no game or anything,
but I eventually met a gal and uh,
we became like serious and it was like my only girlfriend and we dated from high
school til out of college. Wow. High school sweetheart. We did it for 12 years,
but uh, I peed on her many a time. Do you still, are you still talking to her?
She's married now, but we're cool. I kind of her over a few times, but uh,
yeah, we're cool. And she was great. She did.
You both take each other's virginity? No,
no serious lady that is virgins. And then, Oh,
I a prostitute and she bent some other guy, I think, out of anger.
And then we got back together.
So you lost her virginity to a processor or she didn't charge me.
Yeah. It worked out. I had a coupon,
so I got, what did you,
why did you decide to do it like that when you had a girlfriend? Well, it was,
we were kinda on the rocks. So we were talking,
remember when people were talking, but I don't know. We weren't really official.
It started yet.
It wasn't like you had been going for a year and hadn't had sex or we're on the
phone every now and then. And we'd go to prom or something to sock hop together,
but it wasn't too serious.
And then it was why two K was in the air. Do you remember that? Yeah,
when the world was going to end and it was a, it was a bug and it was two,
it was 1999. And me and my friends went to the French quarter.
It was new year's Eve, Eve. And, uh, the best, the best years, Eve,
Eve is way better than new year's. Yes it is. There's no pressure. No,
one's trying to look good. Hurry up and get somewhere. Dah, dah, dah, dah, dah.
The new year's Eve, Eve is the jam, the jam. And you know,
we had this big party to go to on new year's Eve. So new year's Eve, we're like,
Hey, let's do the quarter. We're right here. Let's do it. So, uh, I,
I w I'm out with friends,
I see a woman on the balcony and she's just flashing at the Ramada hotel on
bourbon. I'll never forget it. And she was an older, uh, you know,
she she'd seen some winters say that she was a little,
you know, a tear. You could tell she,
she looked like Jennifer Aniston after a good fistfight. And,
but she had a leather jacket with no shirt and she just kept flashing people,
which is pretty commonplace in the beginning. Yeah. I was going to say that's.
Yeah.
So there's a buzz in the air and I'm 16 and we're all drinking and.
And uh, so we're just staring at her. This is pre Brazzers.
So we're just like pretend. And,
uh, this was pre, um, girls gone wild too. Isn't it?
Maybe like right there. They're right in there. So were big. Yeah. And, uh,
w she she's a staring and she she's like yelling at us,
like what what's going on with you guys? You know, we're like, Hey,
we'd like to come up, we're around. And she's like, I'll come down.
So she comes down and, uh,
she's talking to us and it right then it's like, Oh, this is game on. Like,
this woman is down for something. And, but we're so nervous.
Cause you're still talking to an adult lady who's, you know, 78. And she's like,
uh, you kids want to come up and throw some beads. And I immediately,
I was like, Oh, she thinks we're kids. This isn't gonna work.
So I just do a hail Mary and I go, Hey, you want to,
I don't want to go on a 2000 a Virgin. And she goes, well, I won't let ya.
And that was it. How old was she? She's probably 50 something really? 53.
And so then what happens? So I, she brings me and two guys up,
my other two friends went and got drinks or something. And, uh,
I remember she opens the door to her hotel room, the door swings open.
There's an old man with a white beard and a Harley Davidson hat and a leather
jacket, just sitting, staring at the door. And I was like, Oh,
we're we're going to die. Yeah. This guy's lovely. He has a gun. That's exactly.
He had, I guarantee you, he had a gun. I'm sure he had boots on. He had a knife.
I was going to say he was probably packed all. Yeah, no doubt about it.
This guy came out of like some crazy like Nashville or something.
This guy was like a biker guy. So he goes, which one is it?
And she pointed to me and he goes, all right, you too,
let's go have some beers on the balcony. And you know, now we're kind of like,
when your buddies now got to go outside and drink with this dude. Yeah.
But you know, they're cool with it. Cause they just want the booze, you know?
So they're like, ah, it. Let's see what happens. That's how it was.
But we were feral. We would just did. Whim, no, no plans. And uh,
yeah. So I've told this story many times, but she just sat on the bed. She goes,
how do you want to do this? And I go, well, I'm trying to act cool. I'm like,
I'll take a blow job first. And she goes, I don't give blow jobs. And I said,
kids off the street. We don't get bloated.
She was like, I'm sorry, sorry. Sorry. She goes, anything else? And I go,
are you clean? And she goes, you want to do this or not? And I was like,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry. And then she just got new. It's a great note.
I know that's one of the best no's I've ever heard. Oh, I know.
I want to do this or not. I'm in sorry.
Madam do a re redo and yes,
under age 16. She's 50. What? 53.
I gotta be more memorable.
Yeah. I just, probably just, I was probably thinking about myself. Sure. Um,
who is this? A couple of whites right here.
And uh, uh, Rickles. Jose?
Yeah. No, I think that's the Gore. And who? Yeah. Who does that look like?
Who's that guy at the Shubert?
Um, maybe an old shoe. Who's the guy at the store opens it up. Alan Arkin.
What's that? Guy's name? Argus. Hamilton.
August Hamilton. Yeah.
Good on him named after obviously a couple of slaves. Let's be honest.
Oh yeah.
Yeah. Good play.
What's up Theo gang gang. We're a couple of Tuesdays.
No. About your best night and your worst night performing comedy. Oh,
I got that for you. Thank you. Cute couple right there.
Thank you guys.
Yeah. You want to start? Let's hear yours, man. All right. Well, one I've had a,
I've had a lot of great nights. I've had a lot of bad nights.
It's hard to pick the top, but I did the, the, the, what is that?
What's the arena here? Staples. No, no, no, sir. Forum.
I did the forum once and that was pretty unbelievable. I,
I just killed at the forum. I just had it. It was just sold out,
you know, open for Schumer. I don't know. What is that?
30,000 people or whatever the it is. 20, 22, maybe 22. Yeah.
It was unreal. And it's in a circle and just rocked it and it just,
everything clicked.
I did the Patrice O'Neal benefit and that was a good one with bill burn vitamin,
which was like such an honor.
And that just clicked that I remember I went third,
which is like the best spot in his show and just kicked,
kicked it right in the teeth. And it just, you know,
when your timing is the laugh and then you, then it just worked. Um,
and bill said some nice things after. So that was great. But the worst,
probably two months ago during Christmas, uh,
did a bunch of corporate gigs. Do you do corporates?
I just did one this week actually. Oh, nice. They're pretty.
They're pretty different. They're not really stand up.
You just kind of like trying to keep these people happy and get your paycheck
and get out of there. You don't want to get any HR issues. Yes. Yes.
And I that's exactly what I did. I had to host a pharmaceutical award show,
big hotel ballroom, you know, like white tablecloth, fine China,
tuxedos chandelier's and I'm hosting. I got no cards.
It's like a stack this high of like next up best sleep aid.
Here are the nominees. Like I was that guy. I had a podium and everything,
and I had to study it and the paycheck was insane. They picked me up in a limo,
drove me out to Philadelphia. I get there.
I'm supposed to do 15 minutes of standup to open just to like get them loose and
then go into the award shows clean, but they knew my stuff.
They watched all my YouTube and they're like, we like your edge and all that.
So just do you. So I just to play it safe.
I did the sign I opened for Seinfeld and I did the Seinfeld set, which you know,
nothing cleaner than Seinfeld. Uh, so I go up and out of the gate,
BOM BOM by every joke. And I'm like, all right, well,
let me pull out some heavy hitters. These always work bomb, foolproof bomb.
So I'm like, maybe I'll get a little dirtier. That'll tell, I'll get him. I go,
I do a vibrator joke. I see it.
I'd see a table of women get up and leave in a Huff. And I go, Oh,
that's not good. So I comment on them. Dry women, huh? Yeah. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
These women were not into it.
And so I had my, my get off to like,
I bring these people up to like give a little speech about some kind of drugs
they're selling and I get off. And the CEO of the whole thing is yelling at me.
And he's like, how could you say that about my wife? And I'm like, wait,
what are you doing? I don't even know who your wife is. And he's like,
my wife is offended. Get the hell out of here. You're fired. You're done.
I was like, wait, what, what are you talking about? I'm in a tuxedo.
I rented a tux from Joseph, a banks. I'm like, what?
So I go up to like the curator later and she's like, she's crying.
Cause he yelled at her first and she's like, she's like, you gotta go.
You gotta go.
We're going to find someone else to host it the whole three more hours in the
show. And I just had to get in the car and go back to Philly. I mean,
go back to New York, brutal. I studied and all this.
And it was like a fine lobster steak dinner. And it was like, so high end.
And this was a big production with like, you know,
a sound booth and the lighting guy and the waiters, all this.
And I just had to leave. But, uh,
Netflix is literally has a credo. They'll tell you, Oh yeah, they have quotas.
They're locked in. You have a TV show. We have an Asian director.
We have a woman director in his own. He's not, doesn't matter. It's it's,
it's less about, I think what happened in your,
so I had two good pitches before that.
So it was loose and I was zigging and zagging and I was,
I was on and we were in there with the Netflix guy and we couldn't get the video
to work, to play the sizzle. And it was just showing like the ceiling and I go,
Oh, that's the Kevin Hart sex table. I'm trying to make jokes. And the guy goes,
can you believe that the woman is suing him for that? I was like, well,
I think it's the best thing he's ever done. Yeah.
If it's funniest funny than it's specials. And he was like, you know what?
I produced the last four of those. I was like, Oh, well I'm just, just around.
You know, we all love Kevin Hart. And he's like,
I don't think that's appropriate. I mean, he does. He works with Netflix.
I'm like, Oh yeah, I'm just a calm, just busting ball. I love Kevin Hart.
I wish I was him.
He's a little guy and cute and all that pets to go see it, blah, blah, blah.
And he just the whole pitch,
I just poured my heart out in this pit shucking and jiving I'm tap dancing.
And he was just like, take, take a joke.
That's the whole day doing something right there. Aren't they,
I got mugged a bunch, but uh, yeah. So I, you know,
I was boozing it up in Cleveland, you know, not bragging.
And um, I met this gal. This is years ago, years ago.
And I remember thinking like, all right,
I'm going to be a good guy here and try to do the right thing.
We don't have a condom. So we can't bang. You know,
I'm trying to be a little more responsible and where my hotel room and we're
both kind of, Oh, what do we do in Cleveland? That everything closes.
It's all done. So I was like,
I got an idea because we were both wanting to do something. I go,
what if I put it in the Keester? We won't need a condom for that.
You can't get pregnant in the. Not that I've heard. I didn't know of.
That was the case in gays would be having babies.
A little bit.
So that would also you're you're what you're not considering is Sylvia STI
think about it. I was like the baby's all you're thinking about.
Yeah. Cause what STD lives in the air. Yeah.
Especially the big, the big Hills. So
this was the responsible thing to do.
Uh, she was like, all right, great.
So we went to town and I remember thinking like, alright, you gotta pee after.
That's how you flush everything. I was really,
really trying to be responsible and whatever, when, uh, we,
I don't know if you ever had an STD. No. It hits you about two weeks.
It's usually like 13, 14 days. That's how long it takes to really notice it.
And I remember the next day I was like, God what I got a next day. Yeah.
It was like, so I was like this in my head. I was like,
this is a really bad one.
You know, they didn't do that early.
That's what my dumb brain thought like this is a really serious STD.
So immediately I went AIDS. You go right to the top.
And then he does a lot of gay or, uh, anal AIDS. You know,
this was a one night stand, correct? Yes. And the anal first date.
Yeah. Anal that's Cleveland one night. Is there? Yeah, that's a Wednesday.
It's the Browns Cleveland Browns baby. I was the mascot.
Wow. So, uh, yeah. Yeah. I, I, I had to do the horrible thing.
We all hate to do you text the girl next day, go, Hey, I hate to do this,
but do you have anything I should know about? You know? And uh, she was like,
Oh my God, of course not. Geez. How could yes. And it's just super awkward.
I'm like, all right. I just feel weird. And something's up. I'm just checking.
No, no, no judgment. And she's like, no, no, you, whatever. And I was like,
all right. And then, you know, the next couple of days, it's like, yeah, I am.
I have something bad happening.
Just aching in your Dick in there in it,
in it. Does it burn when you pee pee?
Have you it again yourself? You, I guess hurt.
When that came out. I was too worried about it. I didn't want to with it.
So I was pee and it didn't burn you. The burn is the big tail. That's the,
that's the go-to. So this was a no burn and an ache and a pain and a sting.
So I'm like, so I thought it was some high level, you know,
it's only in your Dick. Yes. It's not radiating in anywhere else. No radiation.
And, uh, I, I I'm losing it. So I go to the hospital and like the,
what do you call it? The clinic, the one hour clinic. And I do a whole test.
They go, you're clean. And I go, well, I got some something's up.
And they're like, ah, it's probably in your head. And they're like,
take some antibiotic bugs. That's what my. So it was like,
all right, so I'm taking it and you know, nothing's working.
So I know this Dr. Guy,
so I just called him and it just kinda like unloaded on him. And he goes, huh?
I bet you got in your Dick. That's not the box. That's what the doc,
I just used the word.
Yeah. And I was like, I don't know.
You ever take that ferry over there from new Orleans over to the West westbound?
Yeah, sure. Mardi Gras world. That we'd go there. Yeah.
I used to take that with my dad all the time. I love that ferry.
It was like a buck. Yeah. That was good times. Yeah. That thing was good.
Never cost a dollar to get into new Orleans from the West bank. Every day.
Those my friends have to pay a buck to get into the city. They got rid of that,
but that was weird as a kid, like, that's kind of to the wankers. Yeah.
It really is kind of, yeah. You gotta pay to get in here. Yeah.
You have to come over there to work and you also gotta pay. Yeah.
It was like that coming from Mandeville was like you had to pay. Yeah, it was,
uh, it was a dollar and then it was a dollar 50 on each side, Dan,
eventually it was just $3 one way. So the other way you didn't have to stop.
You gonna pay $3 up top, longest bridge in America. Yup.
I think it was the longest bridge in the world for a while.
And then Japanese built one longer.
I got caught on that bridge. Uh, but not to get murdered.
I don't know if you've heard about this, but, uh,
we were stopped on the Causeway. Cause I,
we were getting chased by this guy who was trying to kill us,
me and a couple of high school friends.
And there was an accident on the Causeway, so it was gridlocked.
So the car had to park and we're like.
And he got out and he was like shaking the car. He was like a big buff guy.
And we were like three squirrely Catholic school kids.
And he had a knife and he was like slicing the side of the car up.
And luckily the cops at the rec saw it and like tased him and pulled him down
and cuffed him. Oh, that's amazing. It was wild. But I was like,
go on the Causeway. He won't follow it because it's too long.
But then there was a wreck that Causeway man,
cause to me that was a whole nother world over there where you live. I was like,
I don't know what goes on in Covington and Mandeville and all that. That was a,
I didn't know what that was.